There are often situations where using Holstein volumetrics
isn't desirable.
Traditionally, we could achieve these localized volumetric
effects using things such as fog cards.
Thankfully, we can still use similar techniques
to achieve the same sort of effect.
So if we jump back to the editor,
now I have the lit atmos level open,
which should look like this.
And the first thing that I want to take a look at
is this ground plane here on, or I guess more specifically,
the fog cube.
Now, if you're trying to select this and it doesn't as a pro
tip, if you press the T key, the TK
is recognizing transparency or translucency,
allowing you to select those transparent objects.
So if you're trying to select and it's just selecting
the water plane, simply press the TK
to enable it so that the T is in Tango.
And we should be able to select it.
If not, go to your outliner and select your fog cube.
All right.
So if I just raise this cube up,
you'll notice that it is interacting
with our volume metrics.
So how do we do that?
So in the details panel of the fog cube,
I'm going to take a look at element 0 in our materials,
simply double click it, and this will open up
our material instance.
Now, in the parent, underneath General,
I'm going to double click this mCheapGroundFog,
and this will open up our parent material.
Now, a quick note for a more detailed step
by step guide on creating this material,
please refer to the class slides.
This video will not cover walking
through the process of doing this step by step,
but we have included in the slides for you.
So when it comes to making this material,
fundamentally, there's nothing really special about the way
that this material has been constructed,
and particularly what we're referring to here
is we're not using special nodes or volumetric only
parameters within the material.
This is, generally speaking, just material creation 101.
But there are a couple settings that you
need to take note of in order for your material
to actually interact with the volumetric fog.
And to do that, so you can select the main parent
material here, or just click anywhere
in the empty space of the graph.
And if we jump over to the details panel,
you'll see material domain is set to volume,
and blend mode is set to additive.
Now, when you change the material domain,
you'll notice that you lose a lot of the material features,
and that is by nature the design of it.
So what we want to do is apply whatever
we're doing within our extinction.
That should be familiar, because if you remember
from our volumetric fog parameters,
we do have the extinction scale.
So this basically allows us to plug in our logic, which,
again, is this is all covered
in the slides of how to build this,
into the extinction parameter of the material.
Volume, additive, and then plug it in.
All right, we'll go ahead and close that out.
So now that we can see that the fog is basically working,
it's interacting with our scene,
and if I reopen the material instance,
and again, I would recommend that,
play with some of these parameters,
just check them and adjust the settings,
but you'll see that we can
adjust various different things.
So if I change opacity to something like 0.1,
you'll see that it lessens,
and then I can move this volume down.
One other quick note to make mention here
is that the actor that we've added
in our scene here is just a cube.
So I could go over to the place actors
and just type in cube, drop in a cube,
and apply that material.
One of the thing, though,
is because this is actual geometry,
if you intend on your players kind of moving around
in this space or interacting with it,
you probably want to disable collision on this volume
otherwise it will basically react
like any other piece of geometry in your level.
So to do that, go into the actor details panel,
and if you scroll down,
you can see collision presets is set to default.
Just simply change this to no collision,
and that will ensure that players can't step on,
interact, or be blocked by it.
Unreal Engine has another great actor
that we can add to our scene
for controlling more localized volumetric effects,
and that is through a local fog volume.
So let's go ahead and add one to our scene
and adjust some of the properties and parameters with it.
So I'm gonna go over to our place actors,
and I'm just gonna search for local, local fog volume,
and I'll drag this into our scene.
I'll press the G key to go back to game mode,
and something to make note of here is
this volume is propagating and injecting this information
into our volumetric fog.
So if you recall, volumetric fog is based off
of our lights where it's interacting.
So if I were to just add this volume,
this new volume fog, this local fog in a space,
and it's not appearing, all we really need to do
is just make sure we move it into our light.
Okay, so I'm gonna move up here,
and I'll zoom back a little bit.
So you can see that I have this volume now
within our scene, local fog volume,
and I have a few properties that we wanna take note of.
So the first one is radial fog density.
This is exactly what it sounds like.
So I'm gonna go ahead and just actually increase
the size of our fog volume so we can see it
a little bit better, move it towards the door.
And you'll notice that radial fog density
is set to one, and this is very similar
to our fog parameter within our volumetric fog
where, recall, as soon as we get really,
really dense fog, we start to get
kind of this obscuring happening.
So I would recommend for radial fog density,
taking this as something like 0.1 or 0.2,
and you'll notice that it starts to react
a little bit better.
So as I move this into our scene,
again, you can see that I'm getting
this kind of localized fog.
High fog density, fall off and offset,
again, very similar to other fog controls that we have.
We can change these properties as well.
Scattering distribution, again, this goes hand in hand
with the camera and the angle of the light.
Again, if you want this more where you will see this fog
independent of the camera's position
relative to the light, set it closer to zero.
If you want it more only viewable
when you're seeing that light, closer to one.
That makes sense.
And then lastly, you see that we do have fog, albedo,
and emissive, and this is great.
So let's use our just fun hot pink debug here,
and you can see that this does, in fact, change
just the fog within this little volume here for it.
All right, now one other thing,
and you may have seen this when I first
dropped the actor into our scene,
but if I kind of start zooming close,
you'll notice that it starts to clip away from the camera.
And that is because one of the default settings
inside the engine has it set to where
these localize fog volumes
only start around 2,000 Unreal units.
Now, right now, we don't have a parameter
in the details panel to be able to control this.
However, we can do this through a CVAR.
So if you're familiar with how to do that,
we can go down to our Insert Console command,
or we can press the tilde key and start typing.
Or if you're unfamiliar with this,
we have another way that we can add this
just to our overall project itself.
So to do that, I'm going to Window,
I'm gonna go to Console Variables.
I'm gonna add a console variable here,
and I'm gonna start typing r.localFogVolume,
and we're looking for our global start distance.
All right, so there you can see
that the default value of 2,000 units,
and I'm gonna change this to something like 500
and press Enter, and you'll notice now,
it makes you start to see that fog,
and it fades out only around 500 units from the camera.
Again, the advantage here by saving it
within the console variable,
we can go in and adjust this as opposed to tilde,
go retype, and do something else.
All right, so that should cover our basics
of how we can get fog cards,
specifically controlling that through materials,
as well as creating these local fog volumes.
In the next video,
we'll lightly cover post-processing volumes
and some of the various properties you can change
to adjust the look of your scene.